what insight about life have you
acquired that seems obvious to you but
might not be obvious to everybody else
this is a tough one it's a deep question
I do have one fundamental recent belief
that have acquired the last few years
that I don't think most people would
agree with but it's such a personal
thing and it came about in such personal
circumstances that I'm not sure anybody
else will get there in the same line of
reasoning that said I'll laid out anyway
which is I'm not afraid of death anymore
and I think a lot of the struggle that
we have in life comes from a deep deep
fear of death and it can take it's it
can take form in many ways uh one can be
that uh you know we want to write the
Great American novel or we really want
to achieve something this will build
something we want to you know build a
great
piece of technology you're going to
start an amazing business or we want to
run for office and make a difference and
a lot of that just comes from sort of
this fear that we're gonna die so we
have to build something that lasts
Beyond us obviously also the obsession
that parents have with their children I
mean a lot of that is warranted in
biological love but some of that is also
the Quest for immortality even some of
the beliefs and some of the more
outlandish parts of organized religion I
think fall into that and I don't have
the Quest for immortality anymore and I
think I came to this fundamental
conclusion
um I thought about it a lot and
we've been The Universe has been around
for a long time and universe is a very
very large place if you study even the
smallest bit of science you realize that
for all practical purposes we are
nothing we're we're like we are amoeba
we're bacteria to the universe
um uh we're we're basically monkeys on a
small rock orbiting a small backwards
star in a huge Galaxy which is in an
absolutely stagnantly gigantic Universe
which itself may be part of a gigantic
Multiverse and this universe has been
around probably for 10 billion years or
more and will be around for tens of
billions of years afterwards so your
existence my existence is is just
infinitesimal it's like a firefly
blinking once in the night so we're not
really here very long and we don't
really matter that much and nothing that
we do lasts So eventually you will fade
your Works will fade your children will
fade your thoughts will fade this planet
will fade the sun will fade it'll all be
gone their entire civilizations that we
just remember now with one or two words
like Sumerian or Mayan you know do you
know any Sumerians or Mayans do you hold
any of them in high regard or steam have
they outlived their natural lifespan
somehow no so I think we're just here
for an extremely short period of time
now from here you can choose to believe
in an afterlife or not and if you really
do believe in an afterlife then that
should give you comfort and make you
realize that maybe you know everything
that goes in this life is not that
consequential on the other hand if you
don't believe in an afterlife then you
should also come to a similar conclusion
where you should realize that this is
such a short and precious life that it's
really important that you don't spend it
being unhappy there's no excuse for
spending most of your life in misery
you've only got 70 years out of the 50
billion or so the universe is going to
be around and whatever your natural
state is it's probably not this this is
your living State your dead State uh
it's true over a much longer time frame
so when I think about the world that way
I sort of realize that it's just kind of
a game which is not to say that
you go to a dark place and you start
acting unethically and immorally quite
the contrary you realize just how
precious life is and how it's important
to make sure that you enjoy yourself you
sleep well at night you're a good moral
person you're generally happy you take
care of other people you help out but
you can't take it too seriously you
can't get too hung up over it you can't
make yourself miserable or unhappy over
it you just have a very short period of
time here on this Earth nothing you do
is going to matter that much in the long
run don't take yourself so seriously and
then that just kind of helps make
everything else work so yeah that's uh
that's an insight about life that I've
acquired that now seems obvious to me
but it's really not I think obvious to
most people related to that practic
Stephen asks what's your philosophy of
life or grand goal in living in other
words of the things in life you might
pursue which is the thing you believe to
be most valuable another great question
I think before when I
it had their usual quest for immortality
fear that almost all of us do that's
coded into our genes and that was
driving me I was trying to build lasting
things create things make money build
businesses write books that sort of
thing now I realize a lot of that is
meaningless that's just stuff that keeps
us busy it's entertaining it might have
some social good it might help build us
as a moral character and human beings
but it's not really the purpose of life
is there a purpose of life that's that's
tough is your philosophy of life that's
tough uh I think the closest I can
articulate and I'll probably change my
mind on this next year is to keep
growing and learning in this short
period of time that you have to seek
truth and to accept things the way they
are to see the world the way it really
is and then just to live your life I
think that's it I think any deeper
meanings or goals just lead to
ideologies which lead to desires and
belief systems and disappointments and
conflict it's better just to live the
life that you have on this Earth enjoy
it while you go try and see things the
way they truly are not the way you wish
they were
and to be in harmony with things the way
that they are easier said than done the
whole secret of existence is to have no
fear Swami Vivekananda
Reflections on overcoming fear in short
words what has been very helpful to me
is to believe that all pain that I might
experience in any future moment is
necessary meaning supporting for my
personal growth and variable meaning is
not going to kill me
this is just wisdom from the Buddha but
Nasim taleb exposes exactly the same
thing through his concept of
post-traumatic growth I'm learning to be
more eager to believe given that I'm
increasingly realizing its importance
and necessity for one's life to believe
in something is what gives us the
strength to execute on our life's
Mission consistently and to make
something beautiful from this life
because if we were 100 rational beings
we wouldn't have a North or destination
to follow so we wouldn't do anything
thanks for watching if you enjoyed the
greeting content in this video you will
love our newsletter where you can get in
your email all the greeting content plus
the latest things that I've been
pondering to subscribe always for free
find the link below in the description
foreign